[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] em
the speaker
has no balls
he gave away his entire speakership just
to be speakers of the house Kevin
McCarthy of course we knew the food what
he was gonna do if he eventually became
speakers that he was going to give away
all his power
um I don't even know if they're going to
be able to pass a rules package so we
have a speaker we have sworn in members
of Congress
but I don't know if they'll actually be
able to do anything at this point
they're really excited though the
Republicans that is especially the manga
Republicans Marjorie Taylor green
putting out a video this morning oh
she's excited about destroying our
democracy and making a mockery of it oh
the fascists are excited especially over
the weekend watching the fascist down
in Brazil
trying their own attempt at them some
sort of insurrection I don't even think
there was anyone in the [ __ ] building
when they went in and Lula's already
been sworn in like they have a
government
so this is after the fact
and I'm going to talk about that today
of why I believe that it's all for show
just like Q Anon ism trumpism
this megalodites in the Congress it's
all for show
all of it it's all fake it's all phony
it's all fraud
every single bit of it
why in the world do would they think
that they could go overturn the
government in Brazil when no one was
there now I will say
because the imagery was
um frighteningly similar similar to
something else that happened I don't
know just about two years ago
in our country
but the similarity at the end was not
the same where they were toting out
hundreds of people
uh in cuffs
from the from the Insurrection down in
Brazil are the attempt the attempt of
insurrection down in Brazil
um that's not what happened
at our capital
it's taken this long
but have no fear because apparently uh
just just moments ago there's a news
that the grand jury in Fulton County
Georgia has been dismissed because the
final report is finished
um and it's sealed at this point so we
won't know what is in that report
what evidence they collected
we'll see and there's news that Jack
Smith is very close and ready to
present indictments to the grand jury
possibly the grand jury pressing charges
and indictments on people for January 6.
uh forget about the documents case you
don't have to call it the documents case
anymore it is very clear now that the
documents case is the January 6 case
man gay
okay they're the same thing it's no
different
he stole those documents to cover up
something
it's it's I don't know a coup attempt
yeah that's probably what he tried to
cover up I'm talking about the Cheeto
dust queuing on her down at Mar-A-Lago
speaking of the Cheeto dust he wouldn't
honor down at Mar-A-Lago
and Marjorie hooffoot green did you see
the image
of Marjorie Taylor green trying to get
Rosendale some [ __ ] no-name
congressman from God knows where
and Podunk USA
who's elected by a bunch of [ __ ]
boneheads because they don't know the
difference
he wouldn't even talk to Donald Trump on
the floor of the house when pandemonium
was breaking out
I don't know I I I completely forgot
this
this is a piece of news that has
happened the last time I had this
microphone did you know Kevin McCarthy
sold out
his entire speakership to the Maca
terrorist
oh right there on the floor too they
almost fought over it Mike Rogers from
Alabama that toupee wearing [ __ ]
he damn near punched Matt gats in the
face I'm not saying I'm not saying I'm
not encouraging it listen there is
nothing better in this world than
watching a Nazi getting punch can you
imagine Nazis punching Nazis oh my God
you talk about some inner [ __ ]
attainment good Lord
listen a lot of people were discouraged
about what happened last week on the
house floor and how the the Maga
Republicans and the Maga terrorists
acted
I am not disappointed
it's gonna continue by the way this week
over the rules package we just won't see
it as clearly
there were some reports of why we got to
see so much on the house floor
and the government
at the Congress the house controls the
cameras
once they gain control they don't have
control over special events
like um State of the Union Address
that's why when we watch the State of
the Union on C-Span you see a lot more
angles
but when you just generally watch the
House of Representatives the floor
from C-SPAN it's boring as [ __ ]
because all you get is the one one shot
of the podium
and then the broad shot of the room it's
pretty much it
you're not going to really see any
pandemonium if it happens off camera but
you did with C-SPAN in the coverage of
the election of the speaker because they
had a lot of cameras a lot of different
angles they were panning they were
zooming
people were reading lips apparently
Lauren bobert at
told Marjorie Taylor green to get the
[ __ ] out of her face
and then I and then and then we watched
as the final vote count happened
Marjorie Taylor green sat right next to
Matt Getz and Lauren bobert was on his
uh the other side of him
so he was in a Trader bit sandwich Matt
gatz was I'm I don't know maybe that's
his fantasy I mean you know they're
above the age of 16. so I mean you know
I'd have to imagine that he really
wouldn't be that interested but I don't
know I don't know maybe they've been
mowed him something or something [ __ ]
knows
but there was pandemonium on the house
floor as they took a vote
Kevin McCarthy just knew he had the
votes he just knew he had him and he
couldn't get there
Kevin McCarthy couldn't get there as one
vote shy he walked
two men gets Lauren bobert on the house
floor to get them to change their vote
before the final tally
they [ __ ] wouldn't do it
they wouldn't do it they wouldn't give
him the speakership in that vote
so finally Mike Rogers of Alabama the
toupee wearing [ __ ] uh you guys
have seen this video we're gonna watch
it today of course we're gonna watch
this [ __ ]
and we're gonna watch the lip reading
one too because we gotta know what the
hell is being said and it's the thing we
need to know
um so uh Mike Rogers of Alabama
decides to uh confront my guess almost
looks like he's gonna punch him out I'm
not opposed to it really honestly I'm
not I don't really don't like violence
but you know what
again
punching Nazis cool Nazis punching Nazis
even better but Mike Rogers comes around
the back uh of the of the seats
to confront Matt Getz
and he's swiftly pulled away by his
colleagues on the house floor
um after that
even even Patrick McHenry was down
talking to Kevin McCarthy and you could
read his lips at that point saying we
have to get him off the house floor
meeting Matt Getz because they needed to
talk to him I mean they were doing
Godfather type stuff whispering in his
ear and [ __ ] probably threatening with
[ __ ] they know about him that they're
gonna expose who who [ __ ] knows what
they threatened this guy with there's
plenty of blackmail I'm sure these
Republicans with cocaine sex orgies and
the like and venmo accounts God knows
what they got on this son of a [ __ ]
Matt gaps that is
but he wouldn't budge he wouldn't budge
so uh they ask for adjournment the
Republicans requested adjournment
and they got the vote to adjourn and
then all of a sudden Matt gatz
approaches Kevin McCarthy and lets Kevin
McCarthy know that he can win with one
more vote tonight
so they switched their votes the
Republicans run down with their red
slips to switch their votes
they re-tally they do not adjourn even
though Republicans
were the ones who put the motion into
adjourn
and by God he got the present votes
now all the manga terrorists voted
present so that way Kevin McCarthy could
be the Speaker of the House my Wonder is
my Wonder is
what all kinds of [ __ ] did he have to
give away I don't know
I mean he took a picture
uh outside the speaker's office with his
name on the plaque I told you the other
day that's the only thing he really
gives a [ __ ] about
he doesn't care about the work he
doesn't care about the American people
he doesn't care about the institution he
didn't care about the office of speaker
I mean other than the physical space
he wants to eat Five Guys in that
physical space
and bribe people in that physical space
but he doesn't care about the you know
the our office it's our house he doesn't
care about our office that he is holding
doesn't give a [ __ ] about that
I mean clearly from his speech he
doesn't give a [ __ ] even about the truth
the first thing he said is he's gonna
he's gonna repeal Appropriations
and I don't know if Kevin McCarthy is
lying or he's just a dumb [ __ ]
my guess is he's just a lying dumb
[ __ ]
but you can't repeal something you've
already appropriated that isn't how it
works that's why these [ __ ]
chuckleheads always with their nonsense
convincing really stupid delusional
Americans about [ __ ] that doesn't even
exist
when when the House of Representatives
approves and passes Appropriations on
the floor of the house that's it that
money is allocated and money is now
allocated for those funds and it is up
to the executive branch at that point to
cut the check
that's how it works it's how our
government works it's how it's worked
for a long time
the the executive the president of the
United States as it is doesn't spend the
money
they just write out the checks for the
bills that Congress racks up
and that's Appropriations and you can't
repeal it once it's done
the other thing too that's a little
weird about what he said about the 87
000 IRS agents of course we know that's
all [ __ ] that's some stupid [ __ ]
Republican talking point that they've
developed in their Trader News Network
over the last several months
and they kind of campaigned on this
stupid [ __ ] that the IRS agents are
going to come after you listen you you
listen
I'm not for IRS agents really bothering
normal people for stupid [ __ ]
but I don't know if you've ever called
the IRS or if you have an accountant and
asked them if they called the IRS but
there is no one
who works at the IRS
they're having thousands of people
retired the 87 000 people that they're
going to hire is over the next 10 years
and most of it is to fill positions that
are going to be vacant from people
leaving the government because they're I
don't know retiring
Excuse me while I deal with a small
cough
but that again
they're terrified that they're rich
little buddies are gonna have a few IRS
agents crawl up their ass and make sure
that their taxes are correct whoopty
[ __ ] do
but average Americans don't know these
things I keep telling you this
I keep telling you the average American
person doesn't know a God damn thing
about our government
they probably weren't they probably
didn't even know we didn't have a
congress for almost an entire [ __ ]
week
they didn't have a congressperson until
Friday night late
on the East Coast
and they they elected one
but there wasn't one sworn in and even
the swarming that Congress person can't
do [ __ ]
there's no rules package they can't move
forward
and the and the Republicans claim that
this is all great government oh they
they made the claim on the floor that
night
as they failed to appoint a leader as
they failed to coalesce behind a leader
and form the 118th Congress a portion of
our legislative branch our government
it couldn't even do that
until late to the night and make all the
deals so that the caucus had all the
power not the speaker himself
but even then
even then they can't get this done
they can't
they won't
they failed but they tried hard to
convince the American people to convince
you and Gaslight you that their process
is how government works and how they
want government to work they're full of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
listen the horse trading back and forth
has always been a tenement in our
democracy it's called compromise
but when you have to trade your entire
[ __ ] speakership away the entire
[ __ ] the entire principle
of how the house works and how the
institution is designed to get business
done for us
the people when you do that when you do
that you are not doing the proper
mechanisms of democracy you stupid [ __ ]
you are trading away
and you are bargaining for your own
power not ours you pieces of garbage
so the Republicans claim
on the floor that oh this is good
government you know we're horse trading
we're negotiating
we're negotiating
this is all good government you're
negotiating your own power for yourself
apparently Scott Perry tried to
negotiate his trying to negotiate
uh to get on the Judiciary Committee
that wouldn't that would oversee the
Department of Justice
a part of the executive branch who has
seized his [ __ ] cell phone because
there's crimes committed on that cell
phone a judge believes based on the
warrant
you have Matt gatz wanting to be on
committees when we know he's being
investigated for trafficking charges
that are connected to Joel Greenberg who
is pled guilty in federal court and is
on his way to a federal prison if not
he's already locked up I'm not really
sure [ __ ]
can't keep track of every single one of
these scumbags
damn
my day would be full if I tried
but that's where we're at
the Maga terrorists now have control of
the speakership
in the house Marjorie Taylor green Matt
gatz Lauren bobert Scott Perry
chip Roy Andy Biggs
all these present votes
and all these go along to get alongers
all trade he traded something for their
support
or their present vote
ever wonder why in this country our
policy is not to negotiate with
terrorists hmm
doesn't seem to apply with the
Republican party anymore
now
there is a stark mirror image on the
other side from the Democrats I don't
know if you uh picked this up
but as Mike Rogers was ripping off his
toupee to slap Matt gatz in the face and
uh Kevin McCarthy and Lauren bobert and
Marjorie Taylor green were all going at
it on the floor trying to get Rosendale
to switch his vote trying to hammer
others to switch to present
so that Kevin McCarthy could trade away
his entire power to just to have the
[ __ ] name plaque on the [ __ ] door
all the while
Katie Porter
[Laughter]
in true Style
was sitting reading a book
the subtle art of not giving a [ __ ]
oh I love that woman let me tell you
something I got this a lot in the
comments
and Katie Porter should be president of
the United States I got this a lot uh
after the Hakeem Jeffries speech the
minority leader
Hakeem Jeffrey's speech as he introduced
Kevin McCarthy and the ABCs of democracy
which is a good clip we might play that
today
that they should be present in the
United States okay people listen
I I listen listen
you need to stay focused okay you got to
stay focused
why in the [ __ ] why in the [ __ ] would
Hakeem Jeffries who is likely as long as
we do our job in the pro-democracy
coalition
and make sure that we gain back the
majority in 2024 and we make sure that
that majority stays for a long time in
the House of Representatives why in the
[ __ ] wouldn't Hakeem Jeffries want to be
the Speaker of the House
you know how much power
it gives a person like Hakeem Jeffries
to have the gaffle I mean not like Kevin
McCarthy he sells it all out
he's a weak piece of [ __ ] Kevin McCarthy
had to genuflect to Trump and the Maga
terrorist Hakeem Jeffries obviously has
his caucus in order
why would a king Jeffries want to be
president and why would we want him to
be you don't want him to be the speaker
of the house are you [ __ ] crazy did
you see that speech
Have you listened to anything ever that
Hakeem Jeffries has said the guy is on
narrative and on message and on point
every single time he talks every single
word that comes out of his mouth
and he's not even have to be measured
about it he just knows where the
Democratic Coalition is going he can see
it you can tell he can see it why do you
think Nancy Pelosi was so eager to hand
the torch to him because he understands
it so well
so why why even have the narrative or
the thought that Hakeem Jeffries would
be the president of the United I do not
want listen I Tony Michaels do not I do
not want Hakeem Jeffries to be the
president United States he's got way
more way more power and he's way more
effective and he will serve our
democracy as Speaker of the House and I
believe as long as we do our jobs in the
Democracy in the pro-democracy Coalition
I believe that Hakeem Jeffries could be
one of the longest serving speaker of
the house that we've ever had
that's right Hakeem Jeffries of New York
could be one of the longest serving
speaker of the house that we have ever
had in our country think about that for
a second think about how effective our
government could be
if we
stop this stupid nonsense where we say
stupid [ __ ] things like Katie Porter
should be the president so should Hakeem
Jeffrey that's the dumbest [ __ ] I've
ever heard here's the reason why and I
don't mean to trounce over some people
that lead comments but listen you're
doing it wrong
you're doing it wrong this is a this is
a guide and a class and messaging and
narrative
there's only one person that's going to
be president until 2028. only one
you know who that is we don't even need
to discuss it
but to think
that Katie Porter
with her Talent with that whiteboard
and her talent to question people
shouldn't remain a congresswoman or a
senator I wouldn't mind Katie Porter
being a senator of California but
the the absolute narrative and ability
to push forward the pro-democracy
coalition
with Katie Porter questioning and
holding people accountable in committee
meetings
in the House of Representative is vital
to our democracy it's vital
you take her out of that position and
put her in the executive branch she's
not going to have that ability to hold
anyone accountable
it's Congress
it's the House of Representatives the
Committees
that have oversight
see this is how our government works
and Hakeem Jeffries as a speaker of the
house oh baby can you imagine can you
imagine what our country would look like
how how how we could embrace the
diversity
move forward
equity and equality
with the King Jeffries the speaker of
the house for a couple decades
guys Young Folks he's Young
and he's eager he's ambitious
he works hard he knows the narrative he
knows the messaging and I again I don't
know if you notice but the guy knows
where the pro-democracy and the
Democratic Coalition is headed
and as long as we do our jobs as the
pro-democracy coalition
I believe that King Jeffries will do his
job
which is to be the leader of the House
caucus of the pro-democracy Coalition
that is the most important thing
we didn't see one not one whiff
of the of the Democrats
banding with the Republicans to try to
make sure that Kevin McCarthy wasn't the
Speaker of the House Matt gatz was
furiously running around the floor
making sure of it even talking to AOC
Paul gozar was talking to AOC
we watched that on camera
so we must stay focused we must in our
mission
to make sure that we get fascism to
crawl back underneath this rock because
folks it's a q Anon World we're just
living in it and I don't know if you
noticed over the weekend but it's one of
one of the major exports of this country
well or Russia it is a Russian export
too Q Anon Q Anon and fascism that's
it's all the same white supremacy
it's all birth from the same womb
got it
so we must we must stay focused here
we must stay focused and our focus our
Focus
must be on how inept the Republicans are
at governing and boy are we going to
have a sweet sweet well to pick from in
the House of Representatives
so over the next two years I would
imagine the House of Representatives is
going to be mentioned a lot on this show
and not only that the Republicans
absolute
ability
to fail
and fail they will big time they'll fail
boy they are losers aren't they
so stay tuned here every single weekday
to the Tony Michaels podcast noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch do not forget to
subscribe right now subscribe to the
YouTube channel
even if you're on another platform come
on over come on over subscribe to the
Tony Michaels podcast also follow us on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod download
every single episode listen if if you're
if you're a loyal listener to the show
uh on any platform do me a favor
for the new year
and go download uh on a on your favorite
directory even if you don't listen to
podcast it'll help us out here at the
show and if you're on Facebook go follow
us at the Tony Michaels if you're on
Midas Touch Facebook Channel go follow
us at the Tony Michaels that'll help as
well did you know I'm on Instagram I
don't have a Graphic for it
but on Instagram I post some stuff over
there on Facebook too Facebook and
Instagram they're kind of I don't know
how to I don't know how to do some of
this social media [ __ ] yeah I get tired
of it no I'm serious I get tired of this
[ __ ] yeah I'm I'm sick of elon's Twitter
I don't like to learn Mastodon but go
follow [ __ ] go follow up post some
stupid [ __ ] there you know I got all the
hot takes the [ __ ] I'm takes uh you're
the best audience in the world thanks
for joining us on this Monday again
we're gonna do two full hours today as
we do every single weekday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific don't go anywhere
I'm gonna show you all these clips of
Brazil the house floor I want to show
you some Steve Bannon [ __ ] why he's
stoking this Brazil stuff
I've got this clip of Marjorie tether
Green's super excited about tearing down
our government
so don't go anywhere we'll be right back
right after this break
[Music]
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacist the first lesson began
with learning simple phrases and soon I
was putting those words and phrases into
a conversation each lesson takes about
10 to 15 minutes to complete and they're
all really different which keeps things
interesting the app is really smart it
actually keeps track of the words that
I'm struggling with I chose Babble mag
Edition because it's created by smart
white people like me and now I can't
wait to explore meet new friends and use
my new Mega skills with my in-laws all
lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
Monday new week
we're gonna have a rule package no
absolutely not I bet it's gonna be
harder for them to pass a rules package
than it was for him to be a speaker what
do I mean by that they're gonna have to
treat a while away a lot of [ __ ] to get
these boots I don't even know how to
come up with it some of these members
that are moderates moderates they're not
[ __ ] moderates it's like Nazi light
give me a break come on
you're allowing the Maga terrorists to
take over your caucus without switching
your party you're not you're not a
moderate
a moderate at this point would have left
a party you bonehead
you're not a moderate you're just
pretending you're pretending you don't
like this stuff you love it you love it
I don't think they're gonna get a rules
package anytime soon maybe they already
have [ __ ] I don't know
who's watching the floor of the house
um
again that is one uh great thing
about what happened uh also uh um with
last week
was we got to watch the house floor in a
way that we don't normally uh and and
the Republicans tried to spend it as it
was this great thing like I said again
they kept getting up on the floor
anytime they got the microphone
and they were like oh um Margie says
they vote tonight yeah I I figured I
figured there's a uh there's a vote
scheduled rather they vote are they a
motion to adjourn is probably the
question
um and all I mean by that is that uh the
same way as they couldn't get a speaker
that if they if he he can't count votes
can't count votes Caitlyn says that this
is the video from uh Marjorie whole foot
green uh this morning she posted a Dr
Dre song and she says Dr Dre is doing
MTG for using his song Underpants
oh that got me into a laughing Guff
if that's true that's fantastic and good
for Dr Dre I I can't play that's why I
can't play the the audio on the video
I mean I'll play like the first couple
seconds so you know what song it is but
I can't really play it
because it's not mine
and so you know there's copyright and
[ __ ] like that
just like she can't she can't the her
foot green can't do that
and really you shouldn't be using
people's songs that
love our democracy
want to advance our democracy
when you're showing that you're excited
about destroying it yeah probably not a
good idea
oh I can't wait to see that news
um
what was I oh I got this oh the vote the
vote on the rules they're not gonna get
the rules package passed [ __ ] no hell no
and if they don't pass a rules package
guess what they can't do [ __ ] if they
don't have rules to do [ __ ] they can't
do it
see this is this is um this is what I
was talking about last week
when I was saying that what is happening
in the House of Representatives last
week they're ineptitude their absolute
failure to govern
only points out how our government works
right now they were trying to make it on
the floor like it was a good thing
they're like oh well because we can't
pick a speaker and we have no idea how
to govern this is a good thing
listen it is a good thing
when there are debates and committees
subcommittees when there are debates on
the floor of the house for bills
that affect us
but when they can't [ __ ] horse trade
their own goddamn power
because it suits them the way that they
want it to suit them
that's not that's that's not working for
the people you [ __ ] morons
the people not being able to have
leadership because the party that's in
power has the minority ideology which I
told you this last week the reason why
they can't get this [ __ ] done and the
reason why they won't pass the rules
package this week is because the
Republicans in this country are not on
the side of the American people folks
they're not
they just gerrymander mandered their
[ __ ] districts to gain power
not to gain consensus
amongst their [ __ ] constituents no
they picked out the constituents that
they wanted that agreed with them cut
out the rest of them that don't so that
way they can have again the minority
ideology
the delusion in Congress I mean Jesus
Christ Kevin McCarthy starts with this
[ __ ] idea that they're going to
repeal Appropriations
it's already done when they appropriate
funds that's it that's it
you can change a law you can change the
future money
that's why they continue that's why they
continue if you ever notice this when it
comes out of the House of
Representatives
they always put a cap a certain year you
know it's going to last five years
because it's gonna last eight years it's
never uh unending
it's never uh forever when they
appropriate funds
there's a reason for that because when
they appropriate funds it's appropriated
that's it
the executive branch has to write that
check
that's why we continue to have this
stupid debate about the debt ceiling
and shutting down the government and
they continue to do that because a lot
of people don't understand even what
that is like oh we're gonna borrow more
money yeah we gotta borrow more money
because the Congress [ __ ] said we
have to spend it
what do you think you elect these people
to do
but that is what I was saying last week
about why the demonstration of them not
being able to govern
may make people understand how our
government works maybe probably not
there's a great meme out there let me
see if I can let me see if I can find it
um I think my my friend Jeremy London
both says who I retweeted it from I saw
it several places
but he had posted it uh you know the uh
the old Schoolhouse Rock bill becomes a
long come on where is this thing now the
old bill becomes a law type [ __ ]
remember that and they had the song
and and they go to Capitol Hill and yeah
yeah here it is uh Jeremy had it here I
don't know if Jeremy's Jeremy's Jeremy's
an audience member a lot of times
um yes
there we go here's Jeremy and he's got
the graphic here
there's no song to explain this [ __ ] kid
[Music]
uh again there's not a good song to
explain the ineptitude
now the failure of the Republican party
oh look yeah thanks Jeremy for posting
that
I think Jeremy was the first one I saw
posted but there were several other
people that's that's you need to keep
that one handy probably I would imagine
over the next two years you're gonna
need that Meme so make sure to save it
somewhere close and have it in your
favorites and well you can pull it out
and drop it when you need to
um here is the um here's the picture
here let me show this that and then
we'll go to the we'll go to the official
[ __ ] list Roundup uh Gabe Sanchez is
going to be joining us in just a minute
here is the uh here's the picture and
I'll bring this up even well that's that
that one didn't work very well let's uh
there we go let's go to this one there
we go here's the picture of Katie Porter
if you don't see the book there let me
let me pull up a better zoomed in a
picture of the book the book is quite
something that she's reading there and
here's the book she's reading it's
almost like man it's almost like I
co-authored this book or something the
subtle art of not giving a [ __ ]
now
um
this is um
it is a real book I don't even know if
I'd give a [ __ ] enough to read the son
of a [ __ ] to be quite honest with you
um but
not so subtle uh but here's the thing
Katie Porter knew hey she had to him
she's so good at this
she's so good at this
even her shirt is the same color as the
[ __ ] the actual cover of the book so
you can see it well in a picture
again
um someone on YouTube saying this you
guys gotta stop saying this stop saying
this Katie for Prez why why do you want
Katie Porter to be the president of the
United States why she is way more she is
so effective as as a congresswoman do
you have any idea over the over the next
two decades if she remains a
congressperson how especially if Akeem
Jeffries
is the speaker and Katie Porter is in
leadership do you have any idea how
[ __ ] effective and how smart of a
policy maker Katie Porter is
she's one of the best policy makers we
have in our country
next to Jamie Raskin
these people are really good policy
makers
okay
why do you want them to be in the
executive branch
these are not things that compute and I
I know I'm being a little crass on the
audience here but here's the thing we as
the pro-democracy Coalition we have to
learn how our government works and
operates too
so that we can fend off stupid ass
narratives and stupid ass messaging and
stupid ass [ __ ] that I continue to
talk about here including David Pacman
and The Young Turks and any other
[ __ ] out there
that is trying to develop narratives to
be part of the media
to be the media or to rebut the media
[ __ ] the media [ __ ] them we are the
pro-democracy Coalition we are in it for
politics we are going to politicize
every little [ __ ] thing
all of it whatever we have to do
every single word they utter
every single little movement they make
and why on Earth would us as the
pro-democracy Coalition want to take one
of our best policy makers one of the
smartest
one of the smartest Congress people that
we have and the ability to question and
hold
corporations and government officials
accountable like Katie Porter does with
her whiteboard are you kidding me you
think her being president she's gonna
pull out her whiteboard no
she's not going to be able to question
corporations she's not going to be able
to question
the powers that be
she will as a congresswoman though you
goddamn right and you know she will you
God damn right
so we have to politicize this stuff
and to say to say that Katie Porter or
King Jeffries just because they're great
they should be the president that's all
[ __ ] stop stop doing that
stop it stay focused
hold Katie Porter up on high but hold
the Republicans and the Nazis and the
fascists and the America First Nazi
party accountable keep them keep their
ineptitude keep their failures in your
mouth oh this is ridiculous too
Christopher you gotta be kidding see
this is this is the other thing
me for president are you kidding me now
that would be a disaster that'd be a
disaster
imagine waking up every morning and the
president being on a radio show for two
hours you throw in the F-bomb not gonna
not gonna work very well
oh someone says I'm Ryan I know I'm
right
I know I'm right Michael I know
this is not this is not rocket science
you have to know how our government
works and the other thing we have to
understand in the pro-democracy
Coalition is we have to build an entire
party apparatus around democracy
and if we take key players away from
parts of our government and how our
democracy operates it's going to be much
[ __ ] harder that's why they suck do
you have any idea why the Republicans
couldn't come to a consensus with the
speaker is because they have [ __ ]
morons in their caucus who have no did
you see George Santos over last week he
looked like that [ __ ] looked
like he was lost
he didn't even know what lie to tell he
was so goddamn lost in that chamber
Marjorie Taylor green finally [ __ ]
buddied up to him
I mean
Nazis gonna hang out with Nazis and
Liars gonna hang out with Liars
but that's the thing now we're gonna go
to the shitless Roundup here
um really soon
and so we can watch some clips because I
got I got the king Jeffrey's clip but
more importantly I got the Kevin
McCarthy clip where he's
talking about all the things that are
going to help the American people
yeah right
the Republicans have no mind for the
American people it's only for their
[ __ ] hatred of America that they're
going to work hard in the house is to
destroy us and destroy our democracy
I've got some um got some clips here too
of what happened on the house floor
between Kevin McCarthy and Matt Getz
um we have some people who do some rip
uh lip reading
uh so that's that's important
to get to that and I also want to show
you some of the clips uh coming from
Brazil but more than just the clips
coming from Brazil that look so familiar
and look at similar to the January 6
Insurrection on 2021 when the Cheeto
dust Q anoner tried to attempt a coup on
our government
um I want to show you the lead up
because why these Brazilians stormed uh
their their Congress or their government
buildings
um is more important than them actually
doing it because
they were met with a rest and and there
wasn't even Congress apparently they
were already sworn in the government's
already established
they weren't stopping a government from
being established they're just it's all
[ __ ] show
and Steve Bannon is behind it so that's
not surprising
um I also want to show you
um clips of Matt Walsh
yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] box and I gotta
if we get to it
um I gotta show you this that clip of
um Matt Walsh and another
um Christian yay
oh Jesus they're they're obsessed with
gender
um
it's I just I can't I can't
um oh we'll get to it it has to do with
Matt Walsh feeling insufficient when
women like football I guess I don't know
I can't imagine what his insecurities
about this could be but he has them he
has them so let's uh let's do this I'm
going to take a quick break here so I
can cough a little bit I got a little
bit of a cough so let's take a quick
break when we come back the shitless
Roundup [ __ ] let's round up right after
this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another
momentum we're
[Music]
to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
[Music]
you're part of the show
shitless Roundup Roundup all the Tweet
tweets and trendy trends
boy do I have a lot of [ __ ] Clips to
get to I don't know if we'll get to them
all games ninjas holy [ __ ] there's so
much [ __ ] to do today
we're my app to save them for tomorrow
but you know what there's probably gonna
be even more Clips tomorrow that we're
gonna have to go through so well I am
I'm sure uh well you know they're voting
on The Rules packets tonight so yeah
they're gonna vote to adjourn they don't
have the votes for that [ __ ] come on
yeah you think they got I mean at the
end of the day people need to realize
that you know
uh
Kevin McCarthy you know he he sold the
store right like he gave away everything
um and I mean he pretty much had like a
clearance sale
on on the house
that the emperor has no balls or the
speaker has no balls yeah he really
doesn't and I think at the end of the
day people also need to realize that one
of the key key thing I mean they they
tried to sneak in a lot of stuff into
the rules package but one of the main
ones is well one actually I'm really
surprised by this but they're going with
the no proxy voting which is actually
sure okay fine show up to work for once
okay but the second is this is don't you
think that damages them though like
they're not yeah I mean I mean what it
means is that Kevin McCarthy has to walk
this fine line of when he can bring
something to the floor because not only
can he not count votes then he has to
figure out who's in Washington and who's
off [ __ ] venmoing people and [ __ ]
right I mean who's that who's down at
Mar-A-Lago how many of the [ __ ]
congressmen are down at Martin go
getting their Cheeto dust knee pads on
to service the Cheeto dust q and honor I
mean how many are down there that can't
vote so I love that they're going to do
no proxy voting this is that would be
fantastic it's totally gonna [ __ ] them
they're not going to get [ __ ] done and
really honestly the American people
should be cheering on at the Republican
party not get [ __ ] done because the
stuff that they want is absolutely
insane it's crazy [ __ ] it's delusional
[ __ ] and also the big one is they're
changing uh the rules or the sorry the
the number of people required to bring
forward your basically your tenure as
Speaker uh they can with one vote so
what people need to realize here is that
uh this is this is very much kind of
what you just said which is walking a
fine line it's walking a fine line where
Kevin McCarthy cannot piss off anyone on
his side of the aisle because what's
going to happen is wait wait did you
just say the sentence Kevin McCarthy
cannot piss off someone I mean this is
this is I know it's gonna be hard but
what I thought it was going to be
impossible for him to be speaker but
there's no way Kevin McCarthy isn't
going to piss someone off because you
know it's like everyone has uh it's like
the Republicans have their own burn book
right and they've got all the secrets
here and there I mean look it's clear
that somebody on the um
Mean Girls Mean Girls yeah okay it's
it's clear that some someone had some
[ __ ] on on Matt gates to get him to say
uh present again or rather to vote
present right like what we saw on Friday
was uh The Waffle House of
Representative it was the it was the
Jerry Springer of Congress right like if
we really let that go out because and
not only that but it was the two-year
anniversary of January 6th but also the
same year that it took 133 rounds of
votes over two months was the same year
of the caning of Charles Sumner and if
people don't know the story behind that
Charleston Sumner the senator from
Massachusetts was caned by uh
representative uh Brooks from uh South
Carolina I think it was South Carolina
um and it was mainly because Sumner
spoke out against Brooks's first cousin
once removed I think is what it actually
is uh the the uh the senator of South
Carolina at the time
yes he was literally and I see somebody
asking him he was King he was Kane yeah
he came in and beat him with the with
the mountain part of his Cane on the
floor into unconsciousness it took him
three years to recover goddamn the seat
stayed vacant uh I'm gonna go over a
little bit of this into what was that
kind of breaking down this whole like
[ __ ] was she wearing a toupee because I
mean there might be some you know that I
don't know was he but he he I don't know
he wasn't part of the Whig party but he
could have been wearing a wig not sure I
don't know if anyone's seeing the uh the
line I'm drawing the draw there but Mike
Rogers the one that really and I you
know I'm not opposed to Nazis getting
punched and I'm not opposed to Nazis
punching Nazis so yeah watch Mike Riders
damn near uh reach over and slap the
[ __ ] out of um out of uh Matt gatz but
the toupee thing right oh my God the two
bases so basically in a long story long
uh going back to what I was saying
before is Kevin McCarthy has a very fine
line he has to walk he can't piss anyone
off because it only takes one person to
then say hey you know what uh let's uh
vote on Kevin McCarthy being speaker of
the house and when that happens then
Democrats are going to be like yeah sure
okay yeah we'll vote on that we are
united to oust this [ __ ] uh guy with
no balls yeah well I mean I mean to
think to think that King Jeffries isn't
going to be able to whip his caucus
um for the next few years is ridiculous
and again I went over this in the first
30 minutes people saying Hakeem Jeffries
is the president I'm like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about he needs to be the
speaker of the house for a long time I'm
telling you in 2024 we have the
opportunity of making
um putting Hakeem Jeffries the speaker
of the house and he could be one of the
longest serving speaker to house I
believe in our country's history and
speaking of someone who wants to be the
speaker who sold out a lot to become
um
to become the Quasi speaker now she
apparently is being sued by Dr Dre
already for this I'm only going to play
the first few seconds of the song here
but here's the video that uh Marjorie
hoof foot green I put out this morning
she's excited about destroying our
democracy Gabe Sanchez let's let's watch
this stupid [ __ ]
okay I'm not gonna blame them yeah okay
wow Dr Dre is suing uh Margaret Taylor
green for this video apparently that's
the news I don't know if that's I don't
know if it's official I don't know RV
just I mean that's the idea that he
would I think is hilarious well I mean
the first the first order is hey this is
copyright and then he would send the C
as C and D cease and desist yeah um to
say stop using my [ __ ] music and pull
it down but it's still up this is her
video yeah um now um I don't even need
the music and I know this is cringe look
how excited she is about the string you
know you know what oh there's a guy with
the beard I forget his name but he's
always look at her swinging that arm oh
that's all in that arm that gate looks
yeah she's intentionally wearing um not
the shoes that the bomber was wearing
yeah he's wearing cowboy boots yeah well
easy cowgirl boots
oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] traitor what a
[ __ ] she tried to go on Fox I guess
she's back on Fox News
should I do a circuit this weekend and
be like no I'm a normal Republic I don't
believe in Jewish space laborers lasers
I was a q anoner at one point I believe
that dumb [ __ ] but I don't anymore
Joe Biden is the president that's a
silly question yeah yeah oh it's really
I mean it is another example of uh the
gqp Republican revisionism that they
love to play they go no I was never
there never knew him never heard of him
never spoke to him never saw him never
said that yeah
here here's the moment though with her
and bobert you see um oh I you okay so
one thing I want people to notice is
that everyone else is like open openly
talking using their like normal people
right
when Lauren bobert normally speaks she
is normal she's accentuating certain
things she's done when she says it but
she's accentuating right she's like ah
she's talking like an old person where
you'd be able to
read her lips
this whole exchange that happened on
Friday night if you watch her she goes
like this there's
well that's why uh even Patrick McHenry
went down to Kevin McCarthy and was
saying we need to get him off the floor
we need to get him off the floor because
Matt gatz didn't give a [ __ ] he was
pointing [ __ ] and he was saying stuff
they wanted him off the floor so they
could talk to him about this [ __ ] off
the floor because they kept leaning in
and whispering to him basically like hey
we know about the venmo account we know
Joe Greenberg I mean I'm sure that's oh
yeah I'm like look we've got the you saw
what we did to Madison cawthorne right
it would do it again to you right but
here's here's an exchange between Lauren
bobert right here and then uh you're
gonna see Marjorie Taylor green on the
right hand side here watch
now you're not going to hear anything
uh Margaret Taylor Green's trying to
talk to her trying to reach her
and she says get the [ __ ] out of my face
it appears that's what she says Lauren
Robert says right here get the [ __ ] out
of my face yeah I mean it is there is
the non-stop uh you know I I get
criticized all the time for saying the f
word and it's not religious and it's not
Christian enough and all we're the left
is a bunch of [ __ ] you know we're a
bunch of goddamn demons and here she is
on the floor of the house telling her
own colleagues to get the [ __ ] out of
her face I'm not opposed to it I'd tell
Marjorie it's either green to get the
[ __ ] out of my face too I'm just saying
um I do want to play
um uh this um uh a ABCs of democracy
from Team Jeffries here I mean he he he
[ __ ] ran it on him
and I I want people to see this first
and then what we'll do because we'll do
Hakeem Jeffries this speech here just
over a minute long
um and then we'll do the contrast I'm
gonna show you Kevin McCarthy and I'm
gonna show you all the [ __ ] that
happened the pandemonium that happened
on the house and just to give people a
quick call back to the Dr Dre thing it
sounds like it is legit if I look at TMZ
right now the quote is he did not allow
or does not allow hateful divisive
people to use his music so it would
appear that uh Dr Dre is in fact coming
after Margaret Taylor green uh he says I
don't license my music to politicians
especially someone as divisive and
hateful as this one so sounds like uh
she about to
get it get it look around find out Marge
okay let's let's watch this clip of the
Democratic leader who won unanimous
consent from his caucus on every single
speaker vote Hakeem Jeffries and this is
the ABCs of democracy house Democrats
will always put American values over
autocracy benevolence over bigotry the
Constitution over the cult
democracy over demagogues Economic
Opportunity over extremism Freedom over
fascism governing over gaslighting
hopefulness over hatred inclusion over
isolation Justice over judicial
overreach knowledge over kangaroo courts
Liberty over limitation maturity over
Mar-A-Lago normalcy
over negativity opportunity over
obstruction people over politics quality
of life issues over Q Anon reason over
racism substance over slander triumph
over tyranny understanding over ugliness
voting rights over voter suppression
Working Families over the well-connected
zenial over xenophobia yes we can over
you can't do it and zealous
representation over zero song
confrontation
we will love
so Tony is uh well there he is there he
is yeah he's back many people are saying
uh not about you Tony many people are
saying that the speech that Hakeem
Jeffries gave is uh is Akin
to the 2004 speech that Barack Obama
gave at DNC in the sense that it had the
same power the same action to call out
and say look we're willing to work with
you guys we are not left right we are
not Republican Democrat we are united in
this effort to actually help American
people
and then goes on to give the A to Z or
the ABCs of democracy
um and he knew that he knew that
uh
Tony you're muted yeah the one that
stands out to me the one that stands
after me is the Mar-A-Lago one
sorry yeah I had to go running them
take care of something there
um the Mar-A-Lago one is the one that
stands out to me here let's see if I can
find it maturity over Mar-A-Lago
like that one because and the reason why
it stands out to me is because the
entire room's like oh yeah they got
really butt hurt over that one the most
and really honestly did he say anything
that's controversial no not at all
that I mean I mean he's like hey we want
maturity in our Congress as opposed to
focus on Mar-A-Lago and really you would
think that Republicans would be all for
that if they didn't want to focus on
Mar-A-Lago so much right uh but no
no I don't think it's it's quite
impressive because we were texting over
the weekend and I said it's pretty
pretty impressive he didn't say anything
controversial right he just called out
for what the things were
and it was impressive because he got
Republicans to boo against American
values right against this idea of of
America the great we're gonna do these
things and I'm just I'm just reading the
alphabet maybe you guys have a hard time
understanding what I'm doing right now
uh I can slow it down for you and
explain that now I'm going from a
to be
to see but obviously like that subtle
it's not even subtle it's very easy to
get like after he went through b and got
to see like oh okay I see what he's
doing here this is this is a pattern
that he will continue to go through 26
letters and for the Republicans
listening 26 letters are the amount of
letters
in the alphabet just want to give you a
quick quick side note so what he did was
he was really saying like 52 letter or
52 words total or really I guess uh 26
times 3 would be 1878 is that right 78 I
don't know yeah I think I was I was
having trouble with the floor math as it
was going on Friday night what happened
was is um
78 because he put over in he said this
over this right this over this so so
um uh Friday night
um the
minus touch was covering
the the pandemonium on the floor and uh
right before it all happened
um I got a message saying hey our feed
dropped I guess salty their producer
lost power
so and I don't mean to tell on them but
[ __ ] it I'm gonna say it they were like
Tony can you go turn that I don't know
what I don't know what part because I
think I'm pretty sure salty lives out
here in La yeah I don't I don't know
what part of town he's in yeah I don't
know for sure but
um
so I turned the feet on because I was
watching I was I was seeing the reports
but I'm glad that it actually happened
and the reason why is because I got to
watch it live I wouldn't have been
watching it um otherwise I would have
just been following it on Twitter as
people were live doing it yeah so
um because I I've watched enough C-SPAN
I've watched enough of these
chuckleheads over the last week I just
couldn't stand it anymore and I didn't
think he was going to get the votes to
be quite honest because they said he was
going to get the vote so I was like hey
you ain't gonna get it which he did not
get it in the first round yeah they had
to come in and get the feed going and
only lasted for I don't know five or ten
minutes
and I continue to stay just in case
something happened uh I you didn't see
me or hear from me you didn't even know
I existed until yeah you didn't you
didn't hear like a whoo in the
background I mean right and I could go
take a piss
um without being seen on camera that I
had to go take a picture well you should
have timed it better man I mean
someone's going 78 words someone said I
had to take a poop I'm telling you
that's my poop if I could poop that fast
holy [ __ ] man look if guys could cook
that quick I mean you gotta understand
we go to the bathroom and then it's like
phone you know you're on the phone and
then you're in for like you know four
hours you know it's crazy
no I I didn't uh for the audience I
didn't
I didn't pinch off anything I just I had
to get rid of some water here um anyways
I wanna I wanna go back to the to the
pandemonium on the house floor not my
bathroom
um here is uh the Waffle House scene uh
that was on the house floor this seems
accurate is it there were they really
throwing chairs
they were throwing chairs there was a
table set up on the other side of the
Ring they were going to toss them over
break the back on the ring jump over the
ropes hit him with the chair knock them
out drag him right to the locker room
beat him into the lockers drag them back
out strangle them around the ropes and
then toss them over the side and say
he's done you know who is this guy with
this two pay on it is
the real life uh version of a Lego man
yeah I think I think you did a piece of
art like I did uh
this is this is Mike Rogers for people
who don't know this is Mike Rogers I
honestly thought that the toupee was
going to go out the other side right I
thought it was gonna go the awesome way
like I didn't think this could get any
better but that would have made it
better if it would have been like
honestly if the toupee and the tape and
the glue came off
threw it on the ground
I tried to look it up I was like oh did
Mike Rogers did he was did he have
cancer something no he's been wearing
this hat he's wearing this sorry he's
wearing his hair I mean for for years
now and you know as time goes on he gets
a different shade of the wig
um as you can see he's got a other one
that is brown and then he's got this
this gray version
but yeah I honestly thought that once I
saw it I was like man that was like this
like some people will cut their um
their cut their sideburns real close
right like right there above the year
they'll go they'll go up yeah my uncle
Cuts cuts his his yeah his sides really
hot at first I was like this looks this
looks weird but eyes whatever and then
the commotion as I'm following along
whatever so then I look up who is that
guy Mike Rogers so I do a little
background and I find Mike Rogers and I
say wow look at that little headpiece
look at this [ __ ] and I said why does
this remind me of something and then I
realized it's because of my childhood
playing with little Legos literally does
he shave his [ __ ] head and put the
Lego hair on is that what I think I mean
I was like why not own it like if you if
you have donut the hair whatever just
[ __ ] own it just be bald Maga I'm I'm
tough [ __ ] right and it's a horrible
looking too it's not natural looking
like the hairline it's it there's a gap
like if you look on the left side of his
head there's a like the shadow of Gap
here there's no blending like I've seen
some videos on Instagram where they're
like oh I made this old guy look young
again where they like shave into a into
like a horseshoe pattern and and they
glue in hair and they cut it and it
looks yeah yeah and they put you crazy
it looks it's a little natural right and
a good Barber can even blend it in it
right and I'm like why wouldn't you just
do that if you like if you if you have
hair like you're losing hair whatever
right why wouldn't you just do something
like that make it look natural have it
blend in I mean you see people wear wigs
all the time even the ones on SNL where
they put that [ __ ] on within like five
minutes looks way more natural than this
wig right now right now I mean this is
this really though this is a picture of
Mike Rogers uh about 80 pounds and 20
years ago yeah right there was this when
he was I mean he's got is that a
congressional pin on his yeah has this
dude been a member of Congress Jesus
Christ well I think I mean this has been
a lot of two pays ago long enough to
uh vote against things he's been since
2003 so he's been wearing that that way
20 years at least in the last 20 years
20 [ __ ]
a lot of people are like Is that real is
that photoshop no this is real it is not
Photoshop it is in fact which one this
is real this is not photoshopped and
this is also a Lego guy this yeah yeah
yeah yeah there are both things can be
true right now yeah the Lego guy's hair
looks more natural than Michael does it
does I mean let's just let's just say
what it is
um I almost missed this over the weekend
I almost missed this I didn't see this
until yesterday he tweeted this out uh
on Saturday be true yeah
he [ __ ] out on fraud social and so
the Cheeto does cueing on her and
post this on uh fraud social and this
this is the best one he had a bunch of
them but I think this is the best one
and this absolutely shows why he wanted
Kevin McCarthy to be why Donald Trump
wanted Kevin McCarthy be speaker after
he endorsed him for this statement alone
Donald Trump doesn't give a [ __ ] about
Kevin McCarthy here on out because he
made this statement that's it here's
what here's what he says
[ __ ] stupid it's hilarious
and he types the fake news media was
believe it or not very gracious oh hmm
wait wait he's liking the fake news now
in their reporting that I greatly helped
Kevin McCarthy attain the position of
Speaker of the House thank you I did it
or I did our country a big favor oh yeah
friend what a big favor all these big
favors you've done for our country you
treasonous piece of [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
I just don't
I I it's I mean sure like you know this
is here you know what this is this is
the exact same moment when he was asked
on Newsmax and they said Hey how do you
think the midterms are going to be he's
like oh it's going to be bigger than
anyone could have imagined it's going to
be great and that's also when he said if
they win
I take credit if they lose I never heard
of these people and I don't know where
where the people came from but I never
spoke on their behalf
this is the exact same thing if they win
he takes credit if they lose he goes
don't know he never heard of you don't
want to talk to you right he'll call you
a loser he'll say you're a fraud he'll
say that you are fake news and all this
[ __ ] but that's how Trump works
right like he needs and he needs
so much ego pumping right he needs any
wins he can get and if it's someone
else's win he'll take credit for it to
be like yep I did it I won I'm the
reason and now everyone can thank me and
if I put it on true social enough times
it's truth
um
Rob law says here uh heads I win tails
you lose that's a perfect my dad used to
say that [ __ ] yeah okay enzyme when
tells you lose that's perfect example of
what it's talking about can you find the
link except it's a double-sided coin I
wanna I wanna I want the I want the
image
of Marjorie Taylor green holding up her
cell phone oh yeah Rosendale responding
to it I want to show you how much
influence Donald Trump had on the
process of the pandemonium on Friday and
I I really want to show you inside the
Republican Party about uh how he he was
trying to sow chaos
it wasn't working that well because
they're just chaotic themselves
um I believe last week that uh the
Cheeto dust q and honor might have been
the architect of some of this chaos yeah
I sent you the link okay but the more I
the more I um okay let's see because
then here's the thing not because at the
time we were we were hearing Rumblings
right we saw the Tweet we saw the photo
well first first we saw the tweets right
we didn't even get a photo yet they were
they were claims that this was happening
then we got because what people also
need to know is that on the house floor
you've got the representatives or uh let
me just say representatives and quotes
uh how you really use a quote uh Donald
Trump but on top there's a whole sitting
area where you'll see like during the
State of the Union it'll be family
members press things like that that can
watch and observe as the president gives
the state of the union with the House of
Representatives and everyone out down
there right
on the top there is where the Press
circuit is right so you've got all the
reporters the other journalists the uh
photographers and this moment that is
what that's from it's a uh not so much a
bird's eye view but it's a higher view
from the top seating area down
and I mean that's a it's a beautiful
photo I mean crystal clear to see DT on
the phone and a hand being like uh
and then Mark I mean like there are so
many we're we're not we're not even
we're on day nine of 2023 and the amount
of photos that are like oh that's
definitely a photo of the Year Mike
Rogers launching at Kevin McCarthy
Marjorie uh or at Matt Gates Margie
Taylor green holding out the phone with
Donald Trump on the line giving it to
Rosendale context to give context
Rosendale here is saying [ __ ] him yeah
right now the problem is Rosendale they
wanted him to vote present and
eventually uh he did right
um now they they went to adjournment and
they were going to adjourn but something
happened on the house floor where Matt
Gass went to Kevin McCarthy and
basically told him we got a deal and
Kevin McCarthy
urged his members to Red Guard and
change their vote I don't know if you've
ever seen this before and we've seen it
very clear
um on Friday because of all the angles
they had at C-SPAN but you watch all
these members go pull the red card and
then bring it down to the um to the well
to the clerk to Red Guard to change
their vote that is how they have to
change yeah it was it was it was almost
like what because we were texting at the
time and I was like oh that votes are
flipping yeah I had never seen that
before especially ones where you're
dropping 40 votes but because because
the Republicans wanted to adjourn
because they didn't have their life we
don't have it we're not going to sit
through this again it's already you know
so they voted down their own motion
right exactly and so as it was happening
it was kind of like watching like the
stock market of like you know stocks
being sold and and that you know it was
kind of like watching Tesla tank in the
market
uh Yaz who wanted to adjourn and then he
switched to Nays right so you had these
like bye bye bye salsa you had this
moment where it was like watching
uh the stock market like it was like
watching Tesla tank in real time because
you're watching these votes change and I
had never seen that before I I mean I
know that people can switch to vote here
and there whatever they can wait and
then vote at the very end which we were
seeing people like Matt Gates Lauren
bobert do uh during those final votes
because they wanted to either be the
nail in the coffin or they want to see
what the vote count was right and even
on that on the 14th vote you know Kevin
McCarthy was very confident he thought
he had it even with that present vote
from from Matt Gates and then
you know there was photo failed because
they got two cities because again yeah
it can't count they can't count they
don't know how to count well what's
funny is they they he believed he had it
yeah they told the Press we're gonna win
this vote we're gonna vote on rules
we're gonna do all this stuff we're
swearing in after the first vote and
they didn't and it was here's here's the
scene that played out on the floor now
this is um I'm guessing an exact
professionally done uh lip reading of
this exchange Katie Sanchez because
there was a little bit of a tough where
Kevin McCarthy actually goes to
um
goes to Matt gatz
and to to talk to him because this
counting error I mean it it
flabbergasted Elise stefanik who was
taking who was taking a hand tally Steve
scalise was taking a hand tally at the
desk I mean the the cameras were showing
that and they still couldn't [ __ ]
figure out how to count okay I just want
to put this out there uh if there was
ever a case to fund public education
people okay like programs like I don't
know math uh this is a great example
because you have people who are
legislating on all sorts of things your
body your own rights uh you know these
Shady Deals they made in terms of uh
what the concessions were on this on
this rules package that we'll find out
later tonight
but you have a group that are so
confident they're like yeah well we've
got oh you know we've got the kids
go present this and that and I sent you
a photo of Nancy Pelosi and Nancy Pelosi
is literally doing the count on a Wall
Street Journal uh newspaper uh or New
York Times I think is what it is and
she's doing the count and she's like yep
no he doesn't have it like I don't know
what you guys are doing like like I'm
doing this she's like gee he never had
anything like a blue ballpoint pen she's
just doing the math on the paper and
she's like no it doesn't happen I don't
know what the [ __ ] he's doing and the
Republicans are like oh he's got to vote
he's got to vote
used like when the vote came to an end
they were waiting like there was they
were waiting for someone
the clerks went to the tally
we we were like are they gonna call this
are they gonna call this stop it stop
the count stop the count but but they
tried um Kevin McCarthy tried hard to
get Matt Getz to switch his vote and
then I'll show you the mirror of uh
Nancy Pelosi counting but here is I
believe this is a professionally done
there's a lot of work that went in to
know exactly what was said
um while they were debating on the house
floor here trying to get Matt gatz to
turn his vote let's watch so on what
does it go for Bill can you say it
who knows
a really rich doctor said you were a
bummer and I think you don't know
algebra no we're talking science but the
science of what is that a tiger one of
your friends promised me I could flip
you in your face absolutely you may not
do that hit him in his cringy smirk for
real
say any cereal name Cinnamon Toast
Crunch you're like people in the 12th
century
why'd he say it like that you're a
formulated the storm cloud I don't like
you dude and there's a tiger that's it
you two guys sent the tiger right no not
me tiger I mean that is reprehensible
okay yeah okay horrible person Brad I'll
report you to Nadine
I just want your leg bones to be okay
I brought the Tiger
really you got somebody on the organ now
hey man you're gonna pay for dinner
I just hope your leg bones are gonna be
okay I just hope your leg bones how do
you soup your leg bones are gonna be
okay oh my god listen I would imagine as
stupid as that sounds they're cop their
actual real conversation was just as
[ __ ] stupid just as dumb probably
just as incoherent just as just had
nothing to do with the actual problem at
hand they were just arguing over whose
wiener is bigger and who's gonna have
the bigger weiner when it's done and
who's gonna have more power because my
personal power and my power here in
Congress is the only thing that matters
to me to keep myself from getting
indicted Matt gets
um I mean that's really true leap yeah I
mean these these uh uh I mean again it's
it is the The Waffle House of
Representatives you have Mike Rogers
having his mouth covered
right there uh some people I was talking
to some people and they were saying like
oh did he say uh
uh someone uh one of my friends I was
watching was like did he just say
you're a pedo
two Matt Gates and I was like probably
did he probably did because
um he probably is here is here's the
former Speaker of the House
Nancy Pelosi
um and here she is
astonished that Kevin McCarthy can't
count because she's done the count on
the margin of a newspaper and
understands very quickly that he does
not have the numbers he's got 216. you
can see down here her math is 216. they
need 217. yeah she understands this
quickly but hey they're one shy and
she's flabbergasted she's one person now
keep in mind Nancy Pelosi knows how to
do the count we talked about it last
week right she is a very successful
effective speaker and leader of the
House of Representatives right she knows
how
to lover or hater right she knows how to
count she she knows how to count she got
a good education she knows how to count
she believes in education
but here's the thing you've got Elise
stefanik and Steve scalise over here on
their table they're doing the math on a
notepad they were Italian every single
vote I was watching them on C-Span as it
was happening they were tallying and
Counting every single vote they weren't
just doing math like okay there's this
many people they were counting every
single vote to make sure every member
voted the way that they needed to
because they gave they added tally sheet
I would imagine and they probably had
who was hacked to vote a certain way to
win this vote
and they didn't even have that correct
because at the moment that they didn't
have the correct votes on their tally
sheet at least stefanik and
um and Steve scalise should have went
over
to Kevin McCarthy said hey we we got you
got to go [ __ ] whip him we gotta go
whip them we this person flipped this is
our tally sheet this person has flipped
their vote because there's only so many
ways you can vote uh for this and a name
vote it is it is one of those things
where they were very confident they're
like oh we got it we got it can McCarthy
sat back down everyone's like oh good
job you know and then there's a little
bit of commotion like wait what what's
going on uh and then they realized that
they didn't have the votes right uh and
again they had two people two [ __ ]
people
doing the count on on fully their
leadership their leadership they were
doing on notepads that were probably
like the this size uh no I actually if
you look at it it was a completely blank
notepad if you go get a screenshot of
that I'll pull it up because I'm gonna
pull the Kevin McCarthy speech up after
he finally won
um but if you look at that those were I
believe those are pre-made tally sheets
with members names oh yeah they they it
was not like a scratching um thing on
the margin because Nancy Pelosi doesn't
need a [ __ ] organized
you need to know what number you're
gonna need to win and that's the that's
the that's the um the impressive thing
but also that just shows how dumb
Republicans are they had to literally
make a bingo card right to say ah yes
okay you voted you voted you voted you
voted I mean they still didn't get it
right they still had to do the column
count and and she's like okay wait wait
200 111 no shoot I gotta restart okay
like that's what they went through
they're going through this bingo card
tally sheet and they're saying okay
Gregory Ray they had two people two
people doing this count on a templatized
sheet like like they were trying to
count the votes in a Super Bowl like uh
uh game pool like you're betting on
right and that is what happened they had
two people who miscounted and then you
have Nancy Pelosi who's over here just
doing back of the newspaper math and
she's like yeah I don't look I got a
margin about an inch on the on the end
here so yeah I already know they don't
have enough like that's all it took she
had a folded newspaper and was like
because the other thing too is what
people also need to realize that behind
the speaker
up in the area where it's important
where there's a board and it says the
name and it says what their account was
right so so it gives all it gives all
the votes it's a leaderboard essentially
of votes uh and that is what Nancy
Pelosi was basically relying on she was
looking and doing the math and you had
uh Steve's Gleason at least stefanik had
printouts to be like yes no yes no yes
no I mean if they really wanted they
could have just relied on like the
Washington Post they had a literal table
to show you what people voted for in
each round and when they oh so you're
saying they could have just been on
their phones they could have just
Googled it yeah or Duck Duck Go whatever
the [ __ ] they could have just Googled it
they you think they're smart enough to
do that okay they're not smart enough to
know that when you appropriate funds you
can't repeal the appropriated funds that
you've already appropriated in another
Congress they're not smart enough to
know that let's listen to the dumbass
dumb [ __ ] that the current Speaker of
the House is going to talk about in his
speech and unbeknownst to him maybe are
or he's just gaslighting I believe it's
just political rhetoric that he says
they're going to repeal Appropriations
that they have already appropriated and
you can't that's not it's not a thing
let's watch
I know the night is late
but when we come back
our very first bill
really peel the funding for 87 000.
okay so number one first things first
he's like we're gonna get rid of 87 000
jobs we're job Killers number one if
people don't know this is the IRS over a
10 year period okay they didn't just
hire 87 000 people which would have been
impressive they did but also even if
they did unemployment as low as it is
you couldn't even find 87 000. honestly
hired 87 000 people and then we're
repealing
and then you're like all right are those
87 000 people who we just gave a job
just went through uh onboarding just got
through their HR benefits are now fired
oh my God but the thing that people need
to realize is that this plan is over 10
years right so if you average it it's
you know 8 700 people per year
that people are getting into a
government position good benefits you
know you're paying into a pension
uh Healthcare all these things
but Kevin McCarthy wants to be like
we're gonna fire 87 000 people I don't
even know if one person has been hired
yet but here's the thing here's the
thing though is it's it's it's not
actual jobs that they pass the
legislation it's actual money it's
Appropriations to do this hiring over
the next 10 years it's funding for these
jobs because if you actually got on the
phone today and maybe you should maybe
you should just try this out go call try
to call the IRS and get someone on the
phone I dare you good [ __ ] luck to
you if you do because you're one of the
lucky ones um Janie points out something
here the way he speaks makes me want to
puke I have to believe that you're
talking about Kevin McCarthy yeah yeah
yeah yeah and here's here's what I'll
tell you here's what I'll tell you is
that you're not gonna have to have an
upset stomach for long because I don't
believe Kevin McCarthy's gonna be I mean
for very long is it gonna last that's
right the head of lettuce that's the
question well we should do something
like that here just listen to more of
this just a clip of his speech and
you'll understand why he's not going to
be speaker very long let's listen right
yes
[Applause]
you see
We Believe government should be to help
you not go after you
we're going to be literally going after
people Nations aren't challenges from
wide open Southern borders
to American last energy policies
to woke indoctrination in our schools oh
we're not going to come after you okay
so normally normally what would happen
if an elite a leader was elected to I
don't know probably the most powerful uh
or one of the most powerful bodies of
our government that leader would
probably say things like we're going to
advance education to make sure that your
children and your grandchildren receive
a better education than you ever dreamed
of he's like no we're going to make sure
there's no education we're gonna make
sure that you don't get that woke
because he had to throw that word yeah
I mean you have to realize too that
America is low on the [ __ ] poll
uh and the leaderboard of Education you
would think if you wanted to make jobs
available in America you wanted to take
those jobs that were overseas into
America right you wanted to I don't know
uh fund stem programs right you wanted
to fund science and math and
applications because I don't know we're
reinvesting in technology and and uh the
chip Manufacturing in America under
Biden let's just keep that in mind the
chips act right you you've got Biden
doubling down and investing in our
future to help us lower the cost of Chip
manufacturing so we don't have to rely
on jobs and and factories and companies
overseas
but people like Kevin McCarthy and the
rest they they honestly again they
cannot do the math here they can't
figure out that if you invest in
something the end result will help you
lower the cost and build a future
an economy well but you that would that
would have to
um be in a situation where they would be
worried about the American people they'd
be worried about the American economy
and they're not and the reason why we
know they're not is because they don't
know how Appropriations work either that
or he's lying which is he's lying oh
yeah yeah he's he's using words like
woke to [ __ ] stoke the base
because he knows the base is already mad
at him he knows the tail is going to Wag
the Dog and he definitely is no part of
the tail anymore yeah anymore he's not
part of the daily he's all dog now let's
let's continue with his a few more
seconds left here of [ __ ] that he's
gonna do to Americans instead of four
Americans
[Applause]
we'll also address America's long-term
challenges the debt
and the rise of the Chinese Communist
Party whoo
oh my God let me tell you something Gabe
let me tell you something it you talk
about kitchen table issues here holy
[ __ ]
kitchen table issues like the the rise
of the channel Communist party what the
[ __ ] is he talking about as if any
American gives two shits about the rise
of the Chinese Communist party I mean
unless you're a [ __ ] Cuban honor you
don't give two [ __ ] yeah you I mean if
you really care about inflation and gas
prices what do you give a [ __ ] about a
bunch of Communists in China for well
not only that but if they really did
care about this rise of communist China
they wouldn't back a [ __ ] president
who had an active bank account in China
that wow when he was president while he
was president that paid more in foreign
taxes than he did in America I mean
teachers paid more teachers who are some
of unfortunately the lowest paid uh uh
uh public servants of this country who
uh you know again education that
Republicans hate some of the lowest paid
people who come come out with tons of
debt from from getting their colleges
well wait a second I would bet that
these woke teachers all get their own
Chinese Communist bank account I would
say that that's probably I mean I bet I
bet George Soros puts all kinds of money
in that that Chinese Communist Bank cap
that these woke teachers get just
because they're woke but I mean you've
got Kevin McCarthy bitching over here
like a little oh little cuck and whining
about how communist China you have no
control over that communist you have no
control over a foreign entity like that
and none of the bills that you're going
to propose are going to do anything
anything at all that is going to help
stop the rise of communist China because
here's what happens
you're going to propose something it's
not going to get enough votes it's going
to get shot down
your speakership status is always at
risk you cannot Rock the Boat you have
to play it even and all of the [ __ ] that
you're gonna post as right wing
extremists as it's gonna be you just
won't have the votes to do it and if you
and here's the thing you also have to
realize
that there's a whole other body of
government called the Senate
that actually has to vote on a bill too
before it can ever whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa are you saying are you saying that
that stupid Schoolhouse Rock song bill
becomes a law that's actually how it
works that's come on it works come on
well I'm just saying you know I'm just
one more image one more image from
Friday yeah um because apparently the
way he got the votes was Five Guys
um
Pizza earlier in the week by the way
yeah and that didn't do it but Five Guys
put him over the top to be speaker I'll
I wonder now I tweeted this I wonder if
today for the rules package if you'll if
he'll he'll card in Arby's
um to get to get the rules package done
Kevin McCarthy you are a [ __ ] failure
you gave away your entire power as
speakership you have no balls
and I gotta move them and I gotta move
on but speaking of no balls speaking in
no balls this [ __ ] guy Matt Walsh oh
my God
oh boy oh this [ __ ] guy because I'm
gonna move to Brazil but I want to play
this clip here and I got one other clip
of a no bald manly man who's uh scared
that he might have man boobs so he's
blaming it on beer I'm not [ __ ] you
I'll show it to you he's a Matt Walsh
type and they're one in the same now
Matt Walsh is going to talk about
um or try to talk about football here
now you guys know there was a football
player named Hamlin that got um hit on
the field they had Cardiac Arrest they
had to give him CPR there's a whole
story behind it everyone in the country
pretty much knows this story because it
happened live on Monday Night Football
Now Matt Walsh instead of going into the
sports part of it or the or the vaccine
part of it the vaccine denial right he's
gotta hate on some gender here he's
obsessed with people's gender he's
obsessed with what they're doing if
they're a certain gender he's obsessed
with it he just can't focus on anything
but genitalia and what genitalia you
have and what you're doing with it he
can't do anything else so he literally
makes this [ __ ] football thing with
Hamlin where he got hit and had a heart
attack I mean that's pretty simple how
I'm saying it that's that anyways who by
the way uh is doing much better yes he
is that's good to hear it yeah you know
he's tweeting he's tweeting out uh
photos and Status uh yesterday during
the game being like I'm getting better
yeah I was I was very excited to hear
and surprised to hear that he had no
neurological damage because uh he they
gave him CPR for like 10 minutes which
um you would expect someone to have some
brain damage from that but he did not
which is great but this guy is
definitely brain damaged Matt Walsh I
don't know what happened to him when he
was a kid or what happened but he's
definitely brain damaged here he's a
neurological uh effects he can't focus
on anything but gender watch him turn
this [ __ ] Football story about Hamlin
into a gender thing it's Insanity listen
let's consider football itself as a
sport
hey ice starts off great let's football
is a sport let's consider it as a sport
it is a sport but sure yeah right sure
what okay keep going
despite any rule changes or updates to
the equipment it is still a
fundamentally violent sport that's oh
yeah he's getting there oh my god making
points he's 10 seconds in he's made a
point let's go keep going
and and that's what it always will be
is that a bad thing no it's not
okay yeah but I mean you know some that
might it depends on who you are and how
you feel about football maybe yeah you
can I mean like
he's beginning to inch closer to a line
seems like he's gonna make an argument
here let's continue
in fact it is a good and healthy thing
it is good that football is violent it
should stay violent okay now now he's
trailing off into an area where it seems
more Matt while she right yeah
anyone's genitalia yet though
God forbid Matt Walsh speak about
something he actually knows about right
yeah right I mean I'm I'm sure he's
playing a lot of football I'm sure I'm
sure I'm sure the guy has put on a lot
of football pads and helmets and I've
done a lot of gowns in his life two I
have to imagine that if if Matt Walsh
actually had friends
if Matt Walsh actually had friends and
he was invited to let's say an upcoming
Big sports event like the Super Bowl
right yeah uh which I believe is next
month and let's say that he gets invited
to uh he has friends he gets invited to
the Super Bowl to watch with friends you
know having wings drinking beer you
think Elon Elon would invite him to the
super you think Elon would invite him to
the Super Bowl I'm I'm sure I mean he
would take a private jet and fly it
somewhere that he doesn't want people to
know about right watch from there and
then be like stop doxing me and then he
posts from Twitter right but what I will
say is I believe that if Matt Walsh had
friends he went to a Super Bowl uh watch
party was there you know having food
drinking beers all that stuff
he would be the guy that would say the
corniest [ __ ] but would say everything
he had just read about like basically he
had read like an ESPN breakdown of
players and stats of just the two teams
playing and then would say something
along the lines of like oh man that
guy's you know really gonna have a good
game today and it's gonna be like almost
a John Madden of commentary where he's
like look man he's got to get down to
the end of the field to score that's
touchdown everyone's like yeah you
[ __ ] idiot that's how it works you go
to one end you score some points and
then you do it over again and you go
back and forth and back and forth and
back and forth and I feel like Matt
Walsh would say the most obvious but
also the corniest but the dumbest things
possible because he has no idea I mean
he's got a little little what looks like
probably a recreational League at his
local YMCA for the year 2022 or
potentially that's one that he bought if
you look at there's a trophy in the back
of his frame there
but I have to imagine that he bought
that on eBay yeah probably but Matt
Walsh is the type of guy that would
already got it at a garage sale maybe
maybe possibly yeah he's like oh the
parents are like we were getting it was
in it was in the free box you know at a
garage sale yeah that's Matt Walsh he's
the kind of guy who doesn't know [ __ ]
about what he's talking about then shows
up after reading a Wikipedia article on
an athlete or a team and then tries to
play it off like he knows and then ends
up saying just the dumbest most obvious
stuff like no [ __ ] Sherlock that's how
they play the game that's who the team
is we're 25 seconds in and he hasn't
mentioned genitalia yet I'm really
surprised I'm really surprised I bet he
gets to the gender thing though yeah
probably let's listen it is good to have
violent Sports yeah okay we should have
violent Sports if anything we should
have more of them because a violent
sport like football is among other
things here we go a relatively safe
relatively safe and relatively
productive outlets for male energy and
aggression
he just has to bring penis into it he
can't help himself he's like look look
Sports and those Sports things and and
all the violence and the murder and the
killing wieners wieners wieners wieners
like he can't he can't stop himself look
at this little wiener oh my God it's a
little Weiner a [ __ ] douchebag the
guy the guy's like look I've got a beard
and I've got a talk show and my name's
Matt Walsh and relatively relatively
it's totally fine if you want to touch
another man's penis it is no big deal
which again equally responding that
someone hey speaking of someone touching
someone's penis we got to get to the
slap story too don't work we're 15
minutes so let me let me finish this
clip because it gets better about the
gender oh he he really Trails off into
he hates woman land really fast because
there's only I mean there's only [ __ ]
20 30 seconds left in this thing and he
really goes I hate women really I mean
just hits the point really hard
okay there's a reason why many of the
media articles being written and
freaking out about football are being
written by women yeah Jesus football is
not no matter what the NFL is trying to
do football is not for women there'll be
some women who get into it but it's not
really four ones not for you you don't
understand it you're not meant to
understand it oh my god oh this [ __ ]
[ __ ] box he's like look football is only
for people with wieners it's only for
people with wieners and and again this
goes back to these guys being absolutely
freaked out that they'd be attracted to
a woman only to find out that that woman
may have at one time been a man they are
[ __ ] freaked out by this that's why
they want all men to to be violent and
to kill people and to smash people's
heads and they want all women to shut up
and sit in the corner and just and and
take the violence and the beat well he's
the guy he's the guy weird [ __ ]
he is the the misogynist creep perv that
sits in the corner
uh who doesn't know what the game is
about right he's like ah let's blow
around some big skin and they're like
the ball's not made of uh pig skin
anymore at least uh but he's the kind of
guy that would say the dumbest corniest
[ __ ] ever and then he would be like hey
hey uh Susan how about you go get me
another beer you know and she's like go
get it yourself you [ __ ] idiot
and then she Susan would run down the
[ __ ] stats of the game you know
what's crazy through A to Z on how he's
an idiot what's crazy to me is that Matt
Walsh obviously does not have a much
human interaction oh and very limited
um and the reason why is because
I I have a lot of people in my life that
are really big football fans and really
big sports fans and some of the most
Avid sports fans that I know are women
rather it be baseball or football
whatever the sport is that that that is
their team and their game they are they
are uh staunch loyal fans they know the
game they know the players they they
know the strategy and they know the
rules you are so [ __ ] full of [ __ ]
when you say women can't understand
something this is the this is the reason
why these boneheads are losing yeah this
is the reason why they're losing is
because they he at his core believes
that women are [ __ ] dumb he is such a
[ __ ] idiot that shows you how uh
where because here's the thing when you
don't have an argument you attack who
might be perceived in the situation as
the weakest most vulnerable Target right
if I can make them seem small I can
appear bigger and better and smarter and
more powerful
and I can tell you from personal
experience uh I'm in a fantasy football
league with a bunch of college friends
and we've got some uh who's the best who
who
one of the best is my buddy's wife who's
in the league because she [ __ ] knows
she's [ __ ] one she wins last year and
I think she won the year prior to that
let me let me finish let me finish let
me finish this clip and then I'll I'll
give my commentary because we gotta move
to the slab story and then Brazil this
is actually a man's thing no it's all
right
this is why violent games have existed
in every society going back to primitive
times no it's because men are stupid
channeling and not because they're vital
aggression male aggression it's because
men are stupid listen women need to
control things and the reason why is
because women are smarter than men way
smarter than men the reason I can prove
it to you we have [ __ ] this [ __ ] up
long enough if you're not aware how
[ __ ] bad of a situation our our
planet is in alone women if they if we
would have not
brutalize them and made sure that their
intelligence was in power our planet
wouldn't be in the shape that it's in no
[ __ ] way would women tolerate a human
existence destroying our planet they
just wouldn't have let it happen right
but men ah they don't give a [ __ ] about
anyone but themselves well I mean also
there's there was a just a quick note
there was a social there was a social
program you can just easily uh find this
on on YouTube or on Twitter and they
they took they took two houses right and
they took uh young boys and young girls
I think below the age of of 12 or 10. uh
and they basically were like all right
uh uh we're gonna give you you know
we're gonna let you guys kind of run the
thing here's your food here's your
resources
we're gonna see how this plays out
and the girls obviously knew how to do
things right they knew how to work
together and figure out each other's
strengths the boys were destructive they
were [ __ ] throwing [ __ ] down the
stairs
just dumb as [ __ ] they had to intervene
when like the girls found a cat they
like helped the cat gave milk whatever
I'm like all right the cat's gotta go we
can't be in charges the girls knew that
they're like look we can't do this right
now the boys were over here [ __ ]
torturing animals they had to step in
and be like okay we gotta stop this
right now like that it's the [ __ ]
Lord of the Flies when the boys get
involved we [ __ ] [ __ ] up it's Lord of
the Flies stupid I'm not saying that
girls also can't have their issues and
stuff but they're clearly more [ __ ]
organized and they have their [ __ ]
together when it comes to actually like
society and civilization you know the
reason you don't want you don't want to
one of the reasons you want to know one
of the reasons why men are so insecure
about themselves everyone thinks women
are the insecure no they're not men are
the insane they're the emotional ones oh
my god when someone's like hey hey don't
be so emotional show them a photo of
Katie Porter reading the art of not
giving does that a lot or not giving a
[ __ ] and then show them Mike Rogers with
his toupee wearing waffle head ass
trying to fight Matt Gates on the house
floor like it like he was [ __ ] trying
to beat Charles Sumner with a cane well
here's another example of the insecurity
of this toxic masculinity this guy is
making a case before his church this
guy's a pastor he's preaching here
uh in front of him I'm surprised I
honestly a surprise that this preacher
has a world map behind him it's [ __ ]
weird
um but here's he's he's making a case
that you shouldn't drink beer Gabe
Sanchez cause it gives you boobs I'm
that [ __ ] and you listen to this people
drink a lot of alcohol they end up
getting a beer belly but not only they
get a beer belly they get the man boobs
and I'll tell you why they get that not
only just because of getting overweight
but also because of the fact that beer
has and it hops and there are
phytoestrogen oh my god that actually
hormonally all right you chuckle [ __ ]
listen I know what I'm talking about
this guy movie this guy believes I'm
almost sure of it that this guy believes
that there is no way that estrogen lives
inside the man body in times of my you
just it doesn't and testosterone is not
inside of a woman's body like how the
[ __ ] don't you know
I know what he's talking about he's
talking about a a study that was done in
2017. okay that talks about ipas now
he's he is true in that uh Assumption of
IPA the Hops and ipas do cause that but
it's uh you have to drink a lot of beer
well right over a long period of time
but a lot of beer coupled with your diet
can make you [ __ ] fat oh yeah 100 and
generally when a man gets big he gets
big in a lot of places right and the
general place that a man gets big is his
belly and his chest right like wow
haven't you seen pictures of old men who
drink a lot they got the huge belly and
a pair of [ __ ] I mean Jesus Christ
Seinfeld did a whole episode on the
man's ear for crying out loud
what do you think Frank Costanza didn't
drink [ __ ] ipas come on that's why
you had that nice set of tits that's why
he needed the bro or the man's ear
depending on which side you're also you
know beer can be good you know if you if
you suffer from insomnia ipas can be
helpful oh well you know if you're going
through menopause it can be helpful see
um I I don't generally it's called
science guys drink ipas but here's what
I'll tell you I am not an IPA fan here's
what I'll tell you is that this this
chocolate that I just had up on the
screen thanks because a man has a bigger
chest because they're fat makes them
less manly or a woman he is such a dumb
[ __ ] again he they clearly do not
understand the difference between
a man having a fatty chest and women
having breasts just clearly does not
understand they just don't get it okay
um so one thing we gotta go to here
um talking about another creepo and then
I gotta move to Brazil real quick so
let's take two seconds to mention this
maybe we'll bring it up more tomorrow
you tweeted about this
um CPAC the organization that is run by
ACU the American conservative Union
um CPAC is all the great [ __ ] Nazi
rallies that are thrown uh and Matt
schlapp is the head of it you actually
tweet because they responded to the
allegations that Matt slapped the uh the
head of the acun CPAC
um groped um uh Herschel Walker staffer
a male Herschel Walker staffer you um
they put out a statement and you can go
read this nonsense but
um you summed it up so quickly in a
tweet so why not just read your Tweet
translation match slap is a repeat sex
offender and it took us days to figure
out
our poorly constructive narrative I mean
this is probably three days after the
report dropped that he actually groped
someone now the report because uh you
messaged me that Christian Walker had
said something about this and I don't
want to play the [ __ ] video of that
chucklehead but apparently um the person
who has accused him is Milo yiannopoulos
is that true no no no oh also also okay
so basically what it now I don't know if
the Milo story is true
um that's right because Milo
yiannopoulos was not a Herschel Walker
staff ever he was murdered he was Roger
Taylor green staffer right and then a
Kanye West staffer Kanye West never
actually filed yeah
um but who's Kanye you know yay uh and
yeah I'm sure when people see him
they're like oh yay they're like no no
nay nay
um but
uh after the news came out
myly Annapolis now what is true now he
was a speaker in 2017 at
um at CPAC and 2017 is also the year
that his uh his [ __ ] went into the into
the gutter right like there was the
getting fired from Breitbart there was
oh yeah yeah there was the audio or the
not the well yeah the audio video clip
of him on a zoom call on a on a podcast
where he basically was admit I don't
know if his pocket but it's definitely a
zoom call where he was admitting that it
was okay for 28 year olds to have sexual
relationships with 13 year olds and that
audio came out and he doubled down and
then is he a Republican remind me he is
a republican yes
so Milo is like a pattern the guy has he
tells some truths but he also tells a
lot of lies so I don't know if this
story is true is this like truce that
you post on fraud so yeah I think if you
you know every once in a while you find
a needle and Haystack and like that's
true and I think from Milo it could be
true not sure but it also could I mean
it kind of lines up in terms of the
Christian Walker did he back I didn't
watch the video I'm not no it wasn't
about it wasn't about Milo it was about
the staffer and he was condemning Matt
schlapp and he basically was saying oh
Family Values he's really going on this
family values kind of trip ever since
his dad now the thing that I we kind of
joked over the weekend and I was like
this is the moment when uh Christian
Walker realizes that the whole
Republican party is a toxic Cesspool of
uh of sexual offenders and sexual
predators of people who are grooming uh
they are you know raping the molesting
harassing that's the party that's the
party that just gained we'll call it
majority in quotes right now of the
house but really doesn't have it
um and they're also the party that's
trying to negotiate rules packages that
would help benefit to avoid any criminal
prosecution against them which is never
going to happen because the doj gonna be
like you can go [ __ ] yourself on that
but
but speaking of which you also have
those same people who now run the house
are trying to remove themselves from any
culpability of being investigated for
the January 6th Insurrection Brazil two
years and two days are we sure this are
we sure this is Brazil let's take a look
at this clip here and see if this if
that we recognize this
oh it definitely looks like Brazil yeah
a lot of red yellow taking a photo we
got a barricade down we got a lot of
people
uh we got flags banners
now I'm assuming that this building is
their government building I don't know
Brazil very well I don't know I even
know the Brazilian government very well
but we all know that Lula one and
bolsonaro he's been in Orlando walking
around in like Publix yeah you know
Publix and he's in an he's staying in a
neighborhood oh really uh where I think
it's other Brazilian kind of not
refugees it's like an expat kind of it
almost feels like he went to Florida for
a reason doesn't it
there's someone else who um maybe failed
at one of these now here's the thing I
want everyone to understand
um this [ __ ] over in Brazil over the
weekend it is a very astonishing to see
uh the Q Anon moving the Q Anon delusion
doing the same thing in Brazil that it
did here yeah but here's the difference
I want to give you reassurance on this
number one the government has already
been established there okay so actually
I believe that what this is is stoked by
a bunch of [ __ ] boneheads here trying
to make it look like they're
overthrowing governments
so they can convince other Q Anon
deluded people here again to do this
stupid [ __ ] again here because they know
it's coming because these indictments on
Trump and these others are coming here
is Steve Bannon and Jason Miller and I
don't know if anyone knows this either
Jason Miller was detained in Brazil what
was it about six months ago uh as he was
yeah yeah I think it was
um as he was coming in or leaving
um but someone says Bannon is involved
in the chat band and this is absolute
bannon's doing
um this is Trump's doing this is all
using the Brazilian government and the
image of insurrection there to cause
another Insurrection here
um September is he was this was in
September oh yeah briefly detained in
Brazil right here here's here's an
interview though with these two [ __ ]
traitors to our country
um and really honestly I see Jason
Miller as the as the um
the spy on Trump for Bannon yeah I used
to be Roger Stone's boy but he really
[ __ ] pissed off Roger Stone so he's
bannon's boy now I I believe Jason
Miller and Trump if you can hear me I
wouldn't say [ __ ] to [ __ ] Jason
Miller
um I wouldn't [ __ ] have that guy in
the same goddamn room as you because he
is bannon's little ear you dumb ass and
remember during the January 6 hearings
many people might remember Jason Miller
as the bane of uh depositions
um you know wore that face mask like a
real sheep you know uh but wore that
face mask and sounded like a little bit
like Bane giving his testimony as to how
Trump said certain things or did certain
things definitely how he tried to incite
a a riot like we saw in Brazil well here
is here's the uh thumb looking
[ __ ] and uh scabby Steve Bannon
let's hear what these two chuckle [ __ ]
had to say about Brazil way back when
and they're trying to stoke an
overthrowing of a democracy again so I
want to miss a political update what's
happening there and what's your feel for
what's happening on the ground Jason
well Steve great to be with you this
evening glad that you're covering Brazil
where we are uh obviously we launched
together just 60 days ago I haven't been
down there with President bolsonaro a
lot I mean it's it's a pretty nutty
stuff uh but one of the things that
we're always going to stand for Steve is
Free Speech the ability for folks to
express their beliefs and in fact I had
a great conversation with a member of uh
of their Congress just the other night
talking about how their writing what
effectively would be their version of a
First Amendment for free speech rights
and I think that's one thing is
Americans too often we take for granted
uh the aspect of Free Speech but Steve
they're talking upwards of a half
million uh proud Patriots it'll be uh
okay okay I'm gonna stop it here and the
reason why is because it doesn't make
sense to us people who are listening
because it doesn't make sense what
they're saying the nonsense that they're
not but it's all Q Anon code words it's
all this [ __ ] stupid Patriot talk
free speech nonsense that that Elon Musk
has bought into that Donald Trump has
bought into that they are part of the
this this small ecosphere that is
absolutely controlling their [ __ ]
minds and his mind [ __ ] them yeah and
again they don't give two shits
about Bolton air Lula or Brazil all
Steve Bannon wants to do is give the
illusion that hey this is happening
around the world it's not just here that
the the Deep state is affecting
governments and they're they're choosing
the cabal is is making sure to to change
change outcomes in elections in election
denial and all this [ __ ] they want to
convince the [ __ ] sheep here the
delusional mogulanites that this is
happening everywhere so that way they
believe it happening here even more when
they say it's happening here that's all
this stupid [ __ ] is and really the the
um the fact that these [ __ ] dumbasses
went and did this uh but also not only
them uh there's also a video of them
okay go right you just yeah yeah well I
was just gonna get that I was going to
say though Brazil reacted completely
different the the the first part of the
videos of this Insurrection in Brazil
looked very similar but the the after
videos didn't look as similar here's one
of them them go to break we're watching
the breaking news out of Brazil where
supporters of former president gyro
bolsonaro have stormed government
buildings you can see some of them being
let out some of them went out of the
buildings yeah uh as everyone in zip tie
handcuffs uh so they're being under put
under arrest so they are least detained
in hand guess when they're brought out
of the building now that is a little
different than what happened at our
capital and the reason why is because
the people that went to iron capita were
you know white if they were black it
would have been much different and we
all know that for sure
um Ron Ron had this post here
um this is really [ __ ] weird and I
didn't know what this was generally in
until afterwards because it's not it's
the second photo is not actually yeah
right it's not right right but I said
what in the wish.com is this oh yeah
like what the [ __ ] of course we know
this is um I don't even know his real
name but he's the Q Anon shopping yeah
right the the Buffalo vegan the vegan Q
Anon Shaman and then this guy in Brazil
um
and and he looks the the Q Anon Shaman
looks wish.comy enough not let alone me
right Brazilian version
of the Q Anon Shaman but I'm telling you
people when I say this is a q Anon world
you're just living in it I'm dead
serious about the World Part yeah it's
[ __ ] Q Anon stuff is just not here
these people are being mind [ __ ] by
Russia Bannon and the and these [ __ ]
Trump allies to convince them that
fascism is the way to your freedom all
around the [ __ ] world and that's what
Hakeem Jeffries did so well on the floor
when he introduced Gavin McCarthy is to
say hey these things are not
controversial you being mad about
non-controversial things like destroying
democracy only shows you who you are
shows us really who you are and what you
stand for more importantly what you
don't stand for you piles of [ __ ]
garbage and that's why our Focus needs
to be remaining on the House of
Representatives we're going to keep a
close eye here yeah
the next the next two years are going to
be an absolute
gqp clown circus like these these people
are not real I mean they're real people
but they're not real people they're not
to be taken seriously in the sense of
actually having a conversation and
here's here's Dr Rachel bidikoff for
summing it up in one tweet this morning
about Brazil and these these [ __ ]
Traders here all these tweets from
Republican coup apologists decrying the
violence in Brazil
pretty damn Rich where is your decrying
of the violence and the overthrowing of
the government hear you pieces of [ __ ]
oh that's right you were the ones trying
to overthrow our government everyone
stay tuned don't go anywhere this week
because we are going to be on every
single weekday as we are every single
week Monday through Friday noon Eastern
11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter
and twitch make sure to hit that
subscribe button on the YouTube channel
share it with your friends we got over
13 000 subscribers
you [ __ ] 13 000. I think we should push
for 20. does the audience think they
could help us get the 20 if they think
so 20 we would do a huge push for
January for 20 000. 20 000 subscribers
Let's do 22. let's just do it um also go
to Twitter follow us at Tony Michael's
pod on Twitter download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast
every single weekday on Apple Spotify
and Google make sure to leave us a great
review and follow us on Facebook at the
Tony Michaels
Gabe Sanchez a lot of news from the
weekend packed into two hours I'm sure
we forgot a lot of it and I'm sure
there'll be more news from the rules
package tonight that we'll talk about
tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow Tony on social media at
the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon